esta casa destrozada Y estos escombros
son el resultado de la redada israelí en
yin en la cisjordania ocupada en mitad
de la mañana las fuerzas militares
israelíes entraron en una casa con armas
pesadas e incluso tanques y acabaron con
la vida de varios palestinos entre ellos
una adulta mayor él es hora
no llamaron a los vecinos a las 6:50 y
les dijeron que abandonaran la casa
empezaron a disparar y cuando ella les
dijo que no podía salir de casa mientras
disparaban pararon entonces salió con su
sobrino y empezaron a bombardear la casa
ventanas puertas paredes e incluso el
frigorífico todo quedó dañado por las
balas
una redada que duró tres horas con la
que el ejército israelí argumentó
intentaba capturar a miembros de la
yihad islámica Palestina no obstante los
militares bombardearon un hospital
pediátrico además de matar a varios
civiles y dejar heridos
hay un gran número de heridos nunca
habíamos visto una invasión así hay
daños y heridos
una masacre según los palestinos que les
ha obligado a salir a las calles para
llorar y enterrar a sus seres queridos
una vez más y que también le ha costado
a Israel La amenaza de respuesta por
parte de la yihad islámica Palestina
la resistencia lanzará sus misiles y
disparará Sus Balas cuando consideremos
que sea necesario sí para frenar esta
agresión
Y es que si bien en 2022 se registraron
redadas israelíes casi diarias en 2023
la violencia no ha cesado esta ha sido
la incursión más Sangrienta del año y
podría desencadenar en más